peu
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
là
[Musique]
à
imbécile finir par casser tout ce qu'on
transporte joe biden ainsi à m'intriguer
avec ce chariot j'en suis responsable
l'indiscret de vous demander ce qu'il
contient de si précieux
je vais vous le dire un chargement de
caisse de porcelaine or seul n
son altesse impériale le grand duc
dimitri a horreur de manger si on ne le
servent pas dans de la porcelaine
est ce qu'il ya de plus beau est-ce que
c'est annoncé un poste fortifié du temps
de la conquête
weir trois points ce pays était le
territoire des suspectes et que sont
tenues ces peuplades comme toutes les
autres tribus tard car elles se sont
éparpillés dans le plus direct et
maintenant où l'attendra sociale et le
fond puis la guerre et se contente de
soigner leurs troupeaux
rouge pour un berger un la parole ils
sont sur le pied de guerre
on est la formation de combat qu'à terre
fraîchement touché gagnant
[Musique]
allez
tiens
[Applaudissements]
bon
oh
[Musique]
et
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on ne peut tolérer que ce genre
d'agitation deviennent général nous n'en
sommes pas là sir un peu d'agitation un
peu de désordre ici ou là mais sans
aucune coordination véritable cela est
naturel sur deux si vaste territoire
non monsieur je me refuse à considérer
cela comme naturel sur son altesse
dimitri est le garant de notre sécurité
sur place c'est vrai et cela ne se dit
pas à me rassurer mon très cher frère
est encore jeune et inexpérimenté je ne
suis pas convaincu général qu'il soit
capable de tenir ce poste je n'aurais
jamais dû renvoyer la balle
je crois savoir pourtant que la province
d'irkoutsk que commande son altesse est
tout à fait tranquille
en tout cas elle a été jusqu'à présent
pour combien de temps du ne peut le
savoir
bon je ne crois pas que l'agitation
puisse se développer le pillage le vol
et la rapine sont les seules choses qui
guide ses tares tard ils ne sont pas
dangereux tant que ne survient pas un
des leurs qui soit un chef ayant la
volonté de les réunir et mes commandes
et je ne crois pas qu'un tel homme
existe nous n'avons rien à craindre
bon dieu que vous ayez raison général
[Musique]
suivez-moi au greffe
oh
[Musique]
tout est là
il
bonne chance colonel
on
[Musique]
vite on nous attend
let's go je n'aurais jamais pensé qu'une
femme soit capable de faire ce que tu as
fait c'est de ta race n'ont pas d'autres
idées pour les femmes car m
j'avais tellement envie de te revoir
j'aurais transporter des montagnes le
plus dur reste à faire
est ce que mes ordres ont été exécutés
on attend avec une impatience
nous n'avons pas pu contrôler que veux
tu dire que plusieurs tribus sont déjà
passés à l'action
moi j'avais interdit de passer à
l'action avant le soulèvement général
qu'il y a de nouveau quad or il ya
quatre jours fait aux farc année les
autres émirs du turkestan ont franchi la
frontière sibérienne avec cinquante
mille hommes en armes furent farkas mais
qu'est ce qui lui prend
nous devions agir ensemble tu croyais
donc que son alliance et désintéressé
nous sommes tous deux des tartares avant
tout de faire des illusions sa belle
république sibérienne et indépendante ne
m'intéresse pas du tout il utilise pour
servir ses intérêts ses ambitions
personnelles sommes plus au temps que
ceux du scan x tu sais lui non
j'ai toutes les tribus avec moi faut
d'abord vaincre ça pour le moment pu
refaire canétois avait besoin l'un de
l'autre
[Musique]
regardez les
regardez les tous ces kozak que les
russes disent est invincible
les avons écrasé au premier choc à la
vérité c'est kozak ne former qu'une
petite avant-garde rapporte agissent ils
sont battus
nous avons anéanti les cosaques au
premier combat parce que nous sommes
invincibles
rien ne pourra plus nous arrêter
qu'allah nous protège et entendre fut
offert
tu m'écoutes tadjiks ils mentent en
avant la première lune nous verrons
regrouper le grand empire de nos paies
taxi je t'apporte une très bonne
nouvelle pour notre cause
il vend la grève s'est évadé de la
citadelle de faire et s'en va vers la
sibérie pour se joindre à nous une bonne
nouvelle thaçi cette artère de sibérie
lui sont dévouées notre aliments nous
sera très utile par temps d'ici et vite
graille ont déjà tous en selle
[Musique]
et
tiens
[Musique]
bon
ah oui
[Musique]
m
ce que je
mais tout est bien qui finit bien et
nous sommes très heureux ce soir de
pouvoir amicalement lever notre verre à
votre centre si ce n'est rien de mourir
quand on en vient de remplir sibérien
voyez vous ressemble à un océan sur
lequel parfois souffle le vent nous vous
prions de lui pardonner si boisse le
récit peut dire que je suis prêt à
repartir demain pour tenter sa traversée
nous ignorions que les français éprouvés
temps d'amité en ce qui nous concerne
producteurs sont très friands de tout ce
qui touche à la russie croyait que cette
fascination est réciproque
y at il pas fait on
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
monsieur vous qu'il y avait eu la chance
de les voir
il peut enfin à quoi ressemblent tous et
tartare et que sait-on des tribus de
notre sibérie en cet instant votre
majesté nous devons le dire les forces
des rebelles y trouve un soutien
cela ressemble une organisation
concertée de longue date mais vous
l'attendez de notre citadelle de verre
un homme s'est évadé louis cyr mais je
ne vois pas un certain ivan nos gars f1
colonel des plus brillant officier de
valeur et entre autres choses excellent
tacticien
c'est ce que nous disent ce rapport sont
son père est russe et sa mère tard
dégradé et condamné pour haute trahison
pour avoir à maintes occasions professé
des opinions républicaine quand en
sibérie qu'ailleurs et prenez la
constitution d'une république
le rapport ajoute ce qui est très grave
ce traître est en liaison avec des chefs
tartare de diverses tribus s'il en est
ainsi votre majesté cela est grave très
grave et surtout si c'est cet homme là
l'âme de la révolte il faut l'arrêter
cyr à tout prix
où qu'ils se cachent prenez les mesures
qui s'imposent il ne faut pas que ce
traître regard et faten massiri ce qui
pourrait avoir les plus graves
conséquences que l'on contrôle toutes
les routes que l'on surveille mes relais
de poste et les gars de l' empire il ya
15 cents versé jusque là bas il ne peut
pas y est encore je compte sur vous pour
l'arrêter je ferai de mon mieux pour
votre majesté de la plus grande urgence
général dimitri vous le savez est
d'ailleurs outre il ne faut pas que ces
rebelles parvient à s'emparer de sa
personne vous connaissez son caractère
faible et instable
si ces bons général
j'ai très peur que face à des conditions
périlleuses mon frère ne se lance dans
l'aventuré général renvoyé sans délai
par télégraphe les autres suivant mais
comment vous êtes vous échapper je crois
que j'ai bien marché pendant près de 200
verges et sa manche et sans manger
madame sauf une fois à corbeaux que j'ai
pu attraper au moi je suis sûr que
j'aurais préféré mourir d'inanition libe
laissez moi s'il vous plaît vous
présenter l'un de vos collègues
britanniques
monsieur à riz blanc est ce que j'arrive
est enchantée par du tour quel journal
le gaulois et bien messieurs nous vous
laissons il faut mais cher que nous
allions vite délivré cette chère elena
acquis le général courriels qu'ils
racontent pour la 100e fois le siège de
sébastopol journalistes à présent au
papa voulait bien à vous quel genre de
reportage peut-être le même que vous à
la santé du gaulois à celle du dvd
[Musique]
sophie
m
sir est bien ici que se passe t'il une
catastrophe si le telegraph ne
fonctionne plus entre caux libanais
tomsk
il est impossible de communiquer avec
irkoutsk serait ce déjà l'armée le fait
peur car c'est impossible
quelques tribus rebelles sans aucun
doute il ne reste qu'un moyen pour
avertir mon frère de ce danger dans les
délais les plus brefs un courrier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
alors le parcours a été couvert en trois
minutes
j'ai déjà filmé le lido capitaine tu as
un peu trop célébré hier au soir
l'anniversaire de pavel perovic notre
camarade capitaine michel strogoff sarr
lui même vous attend sans le moindre
délai au palais impérial ton nom michel
strogoff majesté depuis quand est une
des courriers trois années m'ajuster
mais avant cela lieutenant dans le
régiment souvorov
oui des états de service très
remarquable cyr strogoff auprès du
général souvorov a participé aux quelles
régions étaient d'omsk or sibérien bravo
nous avons besoin de quelqu'un qui
connaisse très bien je territoire il n'y
a personne qui connaisse la sibérie
mieux que moi majesté et que penses tu
du grand duc dimitri michel strogoff un
officier du tsar dans le corps des
courriers n'a pas à juger l'un des
membres de la famille impériale
fais moi le plaisir de parler selon ton
coeur repos je peux dire que le grand
duc dimitri est l'un des meilleurs
valseurs de russie
rappelez-vous nautique les blessés le
lait si cela vient capitaine je veux
même que l'un de mes courriers lui fasse
savoir cette vérité à irkoutsk que lui
parviennent dans le meilleur délai les
genres du jazz et pour cela j'ai besoin
d'un homme je suis cet homme majesté
bien
alors écoute moi bien le grand duc ne
doit pas tenter de regagner moscou
ils demeureront fermés à irkoutsk et
n'en sortent pas jusqu'à ce que nous
réussissions à lui envoyer des renforts
nos ennemis vont tout faire pour
s'emparer de sa personne pour eux cela
vaudrait mieux qu'une victoire tu seras
responsable de la sauvegarde de grand
duc dimitri la mission est extrêmement
dangereuse
tu dois traverser tout le territoire de
la sibérie et tu le dois pour le salut
dans bir je crèverai autant de chevaux
qu'il le faudra mais j'y parviendrai non
capitaine il n'est pas question d'agir
d'une façon normale
écoute moi bien il est probable que les
rebelles ont des agents partout dans
l'administration aussi bien que dans
l'armée ce dont tu es chargé le bulletin
mission ne doit pas et ne peut pas être
divulgués le blizzard prétend ne rien
savoir de ces rebelles et tu voyages
race ou l'identité d'un marchand aucun
autre moyen personne ne doit savoir qui
tu es personnes et surtout personne de
notre police à partir de cet instant tu
es un homme seul
prépare toi à compter sur ses propres
forces et seulement sur ça je suis prêt
à un geste et voici le saut qui est
accréditera auprès du grand duc ne le
montre à personne surtout le général qui
soft expliquera le détail et fournir à
tous ceux dont tu as besoin
je te souhaite bonne chance capitaine
[Musique]
la porte
des cornes et jeudi 9 par made in aborde
quatre roubles 25 copé
encore un c'est le troisième depuis ce
matin pourquoi les arts et il paraît que
ce sont des espions tartare alors
dépêchez-vous le train la partie
j'aurais dû m'en douter
écoutez mon cher si nous voulons nous
épargner de jouer cette même scène un
certain nombre de fois j'ai une solution
vous proposez m'accueille voyageons
ensemble pourquoi pas entre journaliste
doit pouvoir s'entendre
vos papiers monsieur merci bon papier
monsieur j'ai cherché bouton contrôle je
remercie bien vous le savez où est promu
ne perdez pas de temps quand tu
intercepté un homme qu'il pense être la
sibérie comme nous après 2 qui
voyez-vous vainqueur mais moi j'ai comme
une idée qu'ils la gardent un poids
contenu mon cher blondy
oh
[Musique]
est ce que vous auriez excellent en iran
a vu d'aussi bon là c'était le meilleur
dit que l'on puisse voir sur le
territoire je dois dire que je le paye
quatre roubles le kilo au prix de gros
et suis livré à la tonne
le transport se fait depuis la bande
nourri par caravane étendrait bien cette
fois que vos caravane de man tueries
sont arrivés jusqu'à la foire elles n'y
sont pas pourquoi on m'a dit que des
tribus tartas révolter contre les
principales routes de sibérie brune tout
ce qu'elle rencontre d' absolument faux
le journal dès hier expliqué que nos
troupes sont sur place et que ces
territoires sont pas situés depuis
longtemps ne me dites pas que croyaient
les journaux
je tiens à l'information d'un ami
rentrée tout récemment la vie d'homme ce
qu il a eu beaucoup de mal à sortir de
cette ville en évitant les forces
rebelles qui sont partout seulement il
faire attention à ce que vous dites
ce serait plus sage on ne savait pas
qu'ils nous écoutent
vous avez l'habitude des grands rendez
vous aussi monsieur le sang la
discrétion
oui le bruit court que cette année la
foire s'annonce bien
oui c'est ce qu'on m'a dit aussi vous
êtes dans le commerce monsieur c'est
exact et si je puis me permettre
messieurs dans quelle branche
dans dans les textiles les textiles il
paraît que ça va très fort dans les
textiles en ce moment oui oui ça va très
bien nous aurons à vladimir dans
quelques minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suppose que vous cherchez une place
confortable mademoiselle il y en a une
exprès pour vous s'il vous plaît
permettez moi de le placer dans le filet
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai volé
elle est bonne nous allons une jeune
fille avec nous dans ce compartiment des
je crains que la fumée de votre fille le
risque de déranger une si jeune et
délicate personnes pardon pour se
parfumer vous incommode même au sol sans
prix initié une belle personne de votre
sexe peut toujours appeler ivan
ivanovitch pas la chine pour la défendre
banovic pas lâché et c'est moi qui
serait gentil puisque et aimable avec
vous à me dire merci merci
m
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la vodka
eh ben on va le prendre de haut c'est de
la vodka qui me coûte un rock le 25 au
pecq la bouteille c'est la meilleure
vodka
allez juste eu tout faux steve forget on
ne refuse pas ce live à lewanowicz pas
la chine qui est toujours froid défendre
les jolies filles jamais je ne croyais
qu'une seule personne comme vous et même
pas l'occasion boire un bon petit coup
de votre cas et éboué ou pas répondre -
quand on vous parle laisser cette jeune
femme tranquille approcha libyen je vous
ai dit de la laisser tranquille quoi est
ce que tu te mets ça c'est
extraordinaire je suis pas ravie rana
bishara chic gétules en fait ce qui me
plaît à droite le bras elle
c'est
c'est clair oui
je voulais aller par endroit
c'est insensé
[Musique]
je ne comprends pas nous sommes encore
très loin de nijni novgorod contrôle de
police présentez vos papiers s'il vous
plaît vous essayez gain serait ce pas ce
prisonnier qui s'est échappée de claire
par hasard et alors si c'était moi je
regarderai très attentivement les
papiers de cet individu là bas derrière
nous ils connaissaient en tout cas je
suis sûr que cet homme n'est pas un
marchand comme il le prétend puis je
voir votre passeport s'il vous plaît
nicolas korbanov c'est votre nom oui
vous prétendez être un marchand mais je
le suis où sont vos bagages
je vois c'est un pistolet d'alarmé n'est
ce pas suivez-nous allaient et venaient
de l'information aux normes universelles
de liberté chérie à son aise avec toi
ici dire et on ne peut pas avoir plus la
vaste dimanche en tout cas il ne fait
pas bon voyager dans ce pays sous une
fausse identité
qu'en pensez vous et vous croyez vous
que cet homme puisse être réellement
celui qu'ils recherchent enchères par
être à sa place
vous allez nous dire qui vous êtes
nicolas kaufana marchand je vais la
foire de nijni novgorod pour les
affaires avec un pistolet de l'armée
dans vos bagages
d'accord nous verrons bien ne nous reste
plus qu'à vous y emmener les jeunes ni
le pleurote est une grande ville
commerciale vous devez sans doute y
connaître du monde mais sachez le nous
n'aimons ni les espions et les traîtres
et si vous nous avez menti
rappelez vous vous serez fusillés
florimont dans les faubourgs sergent
goudreault va directement au palais du
gouverneur
à
des stands et par ici
[Musique]
asie
oh
regardez par là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fruits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il vous plaît ce sale vapeur qui va à
kazan et perdrix et quand doit-il partir
demain à 9 heures vous avez le temps on
doit faire le charbon on peut monter à
bord non vous voyez bien que c'est fermé
[Musique]
à
eh ouais
voulez-vous le goûter
bonjour
ça c'est une chance je suis très content
qu'ils aient libéré
ils n'ont pas libéré je me suis ensuite
apprenez you qu'une pâte je n'ai rien
fait de mal
et alors que les vous faire
je dois continuer mon chemin j'aimerais
beaucoup vous aider mais je connais
personne ici important plus je ne
connais personne ici n'est pas venu pour
la foire je prends le bateau demain
[Musique]
je devais moi aussi pour ce bateau
ça faisait pas difficile pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est que j'ai j'ai très long voyage à
faire et c'est de gagner ma vie à
chacune des étapes pour pouvoir
continuer venez
allez
alors les amoureux la bonne aventure
prenez sa tournée ne dit rien
installez-vous mes pigeons
je sais exactement ce qu'il vous faut je
vais vous faire le grand jeu au tarot
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc pour ça ce que vous avez de
l'argent donné
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
on avait vu personne qui donne un homme
de grande taille très vigoureux moi je
n'ai rien vu et vous même mazet
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup
moi je crois je suis moi ma vie
maintenant et l'écart on voulait que je
voulais dire non merci
vous avez tard vous auriez l'occasion
d'être mieux informés je connais
quelqu'un qui sait fabriquer de faux
papiers aussi vrai que les vrais mais
attention ça vaut très cher il est très
gourmand j'ai de l'argent je vais vous
faire une arme
23 38 devant midi près son réseau et
nous n'aurons jamais le temps de me
débrouiller vous sépare avec google et
pourquoi ces ordinateurs ont été
signalés dans la courbe de l'essaim son
désir de voir les ordinateurs
[Applaudissements]
oh
croyez qu'on va passer
j'espère
monsieur et madame ivanov
je vous en prie joli couple n'est ce pas
il est attendu en tout cas que vous me
disiez que vous n'aimeriez pas être à sa
place
comment as tu eu le don fait pour se
sortir de là à l'amour mon cher l'amour
après tout que ce machin avait vu juste
à son sujet le mystérieux conspirateurs
évader c'est toujours le même look
romantique en diable
j'aimerais bien vous retrouver ici au
gagné l'oral n'y a pas 36 route j'ai
télégraphie à paris cette nuit pour une
fois on m'a donné ordre de collaborer
avec vous une race pour confidence je
trouve que j'ai enfin réussi à appeler
longe je suis le même sort que vous à
savon espérons qu'il ya barre
[Musique]
la dia mahdia et vous commencerez prévu
cergy 20 nov
sur mon passeport décidément vous êtes
la nomme bien étrange monsieur ivanov
préférez parle et rit comme vous voudrez
je n'ai aucun secret à cacher je viens
de riga et je vais en sibérie la joie de
mon père peut-être avez-vous entendu
parler de lui alexandre fedor je dorme
hennebelle alfred nobel vous le
connaissez oui c'est ce grand savant
suez de montoir était l'un de ses
correspondants
pourquoi est-il en sibérie
il faut donc en sibérie tôt ceux de nos
compatriotes qui sont contraints d'y
vivre malgré des portes eh oui
[Applaudissements]
opinions trop libéral lui ont valu la
disgrâce du gouverneur de l'île vanille
ma mère est morte il ya peu de temps et
je n'ai plus que lui c'est pourquoi je
m'en vais là bas
vous allez vous exactement à irkoutsk
utile
oui
oui pourquoi
c'est la cloche du dîner vous avez faim
madame ivanoff une faim de loup monsieur
ivana
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
haltiner vous a plu monsieur et madame
merci cet excellent quel est votre
numéro deux cabines tigre numéro 27
monsieur et madame libanais
et bien une bonne nuit
vous voyez ça a bien marché exactement
ce que je vous disais à coupler veille
moins de suspicion qu'un homme seul
vous remercie beaucoup mais je les fais
de grands choeurs voyons je me sens un
peu responsable de tous les ennuis qu'on
vous a fait
prenez la cabine la nuit est très douce
je dormirai dehors
[Musique]
c'est lui
ouais
tu en es bien sûr sûr et certain j'ai vu
hier au soir celle à dissin à un
portefeuille pourrait de roubles je te
dis
alors on y va
ce hangar n'aimeraient pas ça
ce hangar à autre chose à faire que de
s'occuper de nous tiens regarde
tu peux sortir
[Musique]
il n'y a plus aucun risque
m
j'ai joint gym danse
[Musique]
qu'en arrivant nous nous arriverons à
kazan vers 2 heures du matin et à perm
dans la matinée on va descendre à gaza
je préfère traversée l'oural partie
minsk c'est route est plus mauvaise que
celle de pernes
oui mais plus directe des nouvelles ça
remue le ciel et la terre pour le
retrouver
je m'en doute lui aussi je n'y faisais
novgorod que le sahara est envoyé un
courrier pour aller jusqu'à irkut réunir
le grand duc
grand bien lui fasse on dit que cette
année on est son vrai nom et strogoff
n'est pas un homme qui peut sauver le
grand duc ne suis pas aussi sûr que toi
evans et pourquoi ça je ne sais pas dès
qu'on m'a parlé de cet homme après
sentiment me saisit toute entière je
suis sûr que pour toi il représente une
menace
ce sont des astres qui t'on dit ça
cela ne t'intéresse dans pas ivan tout
ce qui te touche passe devant mes yeux
comme dans un livre cela tu le sais très
bien
photo débarrasser de cet homme coûte que
coûte 6,20
à temps
qu'est ce qu'il ya evans
k
m
que se passe-t-il
rien j'avais pourtant entendu du bruit
tout est calme je vous assure
et bien quand ce monsieur bonsoir
oui
[Musique]
oh
bonjour ah ah
bonjour j'espère que vous avez passé une
bonne nuit
une excellente chose voici perm
[Musique]
vous avez une blessure au front
ce n'est rien
je me suis cogné dans l'obscurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'allez vous faire maintenant
je cherchais du travail pour pouvoir me
payer une autre étape pourquoi se
séparer
je dois moi aussi à les haïr août
vous aviez parlé d'autre chose pourtant
ce que j'ai dit ne compte pas ce qu'il
faut c'est que vous n'ayez plus à
chercher de travail et pour une femme
c'est impossible de traverser la sibérie
tout seul et vous quels avantages aux
tirerez vous avant tout
une compagnie charmante et puis ensuite
je continue à croire qu'un couple qui
est marié absolument toutes les chances
de passer inaperçu pourquoi y ait encore
être poursuivis
qui peut le dire mais est ce que la
femme
ne doit pas suivre son mari
alors vous acceptez tattoo n'avons nous
pas déjà commencé
bravo
du tout
3 août
[Musique]
elle reflète pas ce pour ekaterinbourg
de l'autre côté de la ville mais vous
devriez vous dépêcher le départ a lieu
dans quelques minutes il y en a tous les
deux jours merci et
oh
je te donne de roubles si tu nous
conduit au relais de poste pour le
départ oui d'accord
[Musique]
jusqu'à l'oural
ah non ça il n'en est pas question j'ai
une famille des gosses
je ne vous demande pas un carrosse avec
cela vous montrer qu'un valet de chambre
et une souris bravo mon cher de jouer
aux mousquetaires moi je peux faire mon
confort vous trouvez sur un coup de
chance le commandant du bateau voulait
s'en débarrasser
adieu mon cher confrère n'oubliez pas
votre wiimote
[Musique]
alors
pour ce prix là monsieur je vous donne
ma femme tu vas en garde
de manière sûre monsieur je vous demande
pardon laissez moi passer
ba s'est vite vous dire le corps et vous
à cette vitesse laissez moi passer avant
nous envoie sa police en service voici
ma car je regrette inspecteurs nous
sommes pressés la police a tout son
temps
que voulez vous nous aurions quelques
questions à vous poser
nous voulons prendre cette diligence lui
jeter un coup d'oeil sur votre passeport
à monsieur et madame qu'ivanov jeunes
mariés à spa mais concrètement vous
venez vous écoutez inspecteurs nous
avons roi vous avoir posé une question
de moscou et où allez-vous à
ekaterinbourg quoi faire c'est notre
voyage de noces bien c est votre
profession marchand mais quand même
temps allez-vous rester à ekaterinbourg
une ou deux semaines vous y connaissez
des gens
oui vous êtes invités oui mais toi dans
l'étude je crois que ça peut aller à
vienne c'est parfait allez-y voyage
permettez-nous charmant quand on y est
en lune de miel
après tout va attendre deux jours je
n'ai pas la mer à boire pour les
amoureux des achats sûrement mais si
c'est grave
peut-être peut-être peut-on prendre une
autre des licences même irrégulière je
ne crois pas ma ptite dame
celle qui est partie était sûrement la
dernière de la ligne ce qui se passe au
delà de l'oural a hélas totalement
désorganisé tout notre service on peut
acheter une voiture avec des chevaux
j'en doute
il ne doit pas en rester beaucoup tous
ces réfugiés ont pris le peu qu'ils ont
trouvée voiture et chevaux et wii est le
seul endroit où vous puissiez encore
retrouvé les joies je vous assure que
jean trouvera une est bien quand vous
leur ai trouvé revenait donc me voir
pour les chevaux bien sûr jeu mais je
peux vous gardez vos sacs l'un en
attendant
[Musique]
ok
si belle voiture avant de vous en
montrer
voyant toujours en vie
[Musique]
ce faire elle
et la roue c'est une chance qu'elle y
soit prêt avec toutes ces routes ça fait
longtemps que cette partie est-ce que
j'ai aussi une chance de pouvoir trouver
une route il doit bien y avoir quelques
charron à cette ville de perm
bien sûr qu'il y en a bien sûr monsieur
être très bon
[Musique]
m
j'ai trouvé la voiture ils me font les
chevaux maintenant excusez moi mais il y
à du nouveau depuis tout à l'heure je
n'ai plus un seul cheval enfin vous me
l'aviez promis
c'est vrai monsieur mais je n'y suis
pour rien l'armée vient de
réquisitionner les derniers chevaux qui
nous restait que voulait voir quoi
peut-être vous rendra ses avis vous oui
je sais bien que vous m'en voulez vous
avez tort c'est pas un méchant bout
profond je connais une adresse vous
pourrez trouver tous les chevaux vous
venez d chaud ou assis fitch à monsieur
il vous faut y aller de ma part c'est un
monsieur vous comprenez ce que ça veut
dire combien a fait un plaisir de
discuter avec vous je n'ai pas de temps
à perdre combien peut-on 80 roupies
quelqu'un bonjour grégory fm beach
m'envoie je veux des chevaux
voilà ça vous coûtera 500 roubles par
cheval 500 roubles mais c'est le prix
d'un cheval de course pas de marchandage
c'est mon dernier prix art ordures
combien de chevaux eux
[Musique]
à permettez pour ce prix je voulais
choisir moi-même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces chevaux ont été volés à l'armée non
vous êtes un mouchard je m'en étais
douter malheureusement j'ai d'autres
soucis
[Musique]
on ne s'était pas la nature
mais bien vite les chevaux
aux nuits
[Applaudissements]
photo pas s'arrêter un peu pour se
restaurer j'ai déjà perdu trop de temps
et si vous avez faim
regardez ce qu'il ya dans le panier
[Musique]
gt rien
je sais que je vous choque
[Musique]
je sais que je peux pas être un homme
brutal et sans manières c'est vrai leur
gré vous avez raison d'être fâché aller
mais aucun motif de me plaindre
nous avons fait un pacte que je respecte
du reste on épouse doit suivre son mari
c'est bien ce que vous avez dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez tous
aujourd'hui est le jour ou tartare du
turkestan et tartare de sibérie sont
enfin réunis uv comme un seul homme et
quoi notre peuple
oui
à
[Musique]
c'est vite fait refaire toi et ton armé
je ne nous attendions pas si tôt le
bousculer les causes à n'avait-on pas
décidé de nous partir en guerre
après que le colonel augareils nous
aient rejoints mais pas mauvais devant
gagner du temps le colonel hoggar fh
service dans les armées 12 heures il est
le seul d'entre nous à connaître les
secrets des russes nous avons besoin de
lui pour les battre lien ni secret ni
magie nos armées valent bien celles du
tsar romero chat dans le combat
[Musique]
aurais-tu le front de douter de notre
courage il n'a pas suffi durant des
siècles et il sait mieux que personne il
suffira j'vous là sur ces personne n'en
doute
et la présence de l'ami augareils ce
n'est qu'une aide
peut-on nous dire quand aux grèves se
présentera il ne va pas tarder on nous
l'a signalé aux abords de l'oil ces
jours ci
que des situent les sentiers de montagne
sont plus sûrs mais par la route en
arrive plus vite
oui puis être arrêté par les gardes
frontières
pour moi le temps compte plus que le riz
seront je choisis la route
ils sont à voir tome 1
[Musique]
vois rien de me fait pour toi
oui je n'ai pour l'instant tôt pourquoi
il vaut mieux adducteurs le froid sera
bientôt là vous faussez continuer encore
longtemps
oui toute la nuit si nous pouvons merci
tu fait vous nous allons prendre un
court sic je sais qu'il est mauvais et
les cheveux commencent à être fourbe et
se tient prêt anglais au jour pour
pouvoir attaquer la montagne avec des
chevaux frais
douch maroc
oh
bon dieu les cieux est cassé descendez
[Musique]
tenez la couverture faut couvrir les
jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez nazaire ces gens vont peut-être
pouvoir nous aider
venez
[Musique]
bonsoir j'ai cassé un essieu de ma
voiture est ce qu'il ya un charron
capable de le réparer dans le pays bien
sûr il ya un charron au village voisin
il ya un très beau charron à il faudra
attendre que le jour se lève
ne restez pas dehors venez macha ce sont
deux voyageurs qui ont eu un accident
les chemins sont mauvais dans notre
région
soyez les bienvenus chez nous as-tu de
quoi servir d'eux ils vous avez sûrement
très fin vous devrez vous contenter de
la modestie de notre hospitalité
nous ne voulons surtout pas vous
déranger
dites-nous seulement où l'on peut
trouver le charme
la nuit va tomber je suis sûr que nous
trouverons personne je suis très pressé
il faut absolument je trouve et je vous
assure que le mieux et que vous restez
ici cette nuit et je vous mènerez au
village pour reparler dès demain à
l'aube et la petite dame elle est très
fatiguée je vois je crois que vous avez
raison percée vous entendez des loups
oui la nuit leur appartient et personne
ici ne serait-ce qu'à sortir au dehors
après la tombée du jour ce serait
dangereux d'aller au village on est
notre chance vous y serez très bien
asseyez-vous dans la vie il faut prendre
son temps pour toute chose et chevaux
ils vont se faire dévorer il faut
absolument je le met à l'abri ils vont
lui perd dans les vosges faut que de
perdre la vie avez vous une grange où je
pourrais les abriter tous les deux
ecoutez-moi croyez moi c'est inutile
d'essayer vous ne connaissez pas lu je
connais mais ils ont peur du feu il faut
pas laisser faire ça il ne reviendra pas
vivant ne prenez pas ce risque
nadia il le faut 100 chevaux vous le
savez nous sommes perdus chaque seconde
qui passe est une chance de moins
attardés
prenez au moins cela
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
il fait tout ça pour une paire de
chevaux les hommes sont tous des fous
voulaient croire que s'il agit ainsi ce
qu'il ne peut pas faire autrement
vous êtes dont si pressé tous les deux
oui nous sommes très pressés
j'ai tellement peur vous est blessé
c'est vrai merci bien vous n'êtes pas
blessé nous avons entendu des coups de
feu
ça y est les chevaux sont en sécurité
alors c'est bien vous avez bien mérité
de venir manger une bonne soupe bien
chaude
mais nous ne voulons pas prendre votre
chambre
oh je sais bien que vous devez être
accoutumée un biais plus grand confort
ah non non ce n'est pas ce que je
voulais dire je savais l'hospitalité
c'est le seul luxe que nous ayons alors
il faut nous laisser passer une bonne
nuit
je suis désolé personne ne pouvait
prévoir ça je suis sûr que le vous
n'abusez pas de la situation
et
nous avons besoin de sommeil vous et moi
je ne vois aucun inconvénient à ce que
nous dormions à côté l'un de l'autre
vous êtes une fille merveilleuse
vous devriez retirer vos bottes
[Musique]
pourquoi souriez vous cette chambre le
rappelle celle de mon enfance aborder la
couverture
je n'ai pas froid
il y avait la même icône au dessus de
mon lit et du rite et vous donne ce que
mes parents étaient des paysans et sa
mort
non
mais revêtent toujours à omsk oui un
très peu de temps vous la verrez nous
passons bien par en muscles oui je pense
que vous avez l'intention de voir votre
mère non je ne comprends pas je ne crois
pas être obligé d'avoir vous rendre
compte d'aucun de mes actes j'avais
raison
nous ne devons rien l'un à l'autre la
nuit
je suis désolé je ne voulais pas être
blessant
vous êtes très fatigué et je suis aussi
dormait ce serait mieux
bonne nuit
[Musique]
merci merci pour tout souper à lille
c'est pas grand chose vous savez c'est
bien ce qu'on devrait trouver partout
nous souhaite beaucoup de bonheur et
beaucoup d'enfants
bon comme leur mère et vaillant comme
leur père tu as là
[Musique]
mais pas par les deux jours n'est ce pas
et vous ce que me disait hier soir la
femme de logique
elle ne comprenait pas que vous risquiez
votre vie pour une paire de chevaux elle
n'est pas la seule à ne pas comprendre
pourquoi les femmes sont elles aussi
curieuse et bien ça fait ça fait quatre
jours que nous voyageons ensemble
je ne sais toujours rien de vous
que voulez vous savoir pourquoi
avez-vous tant de hâte
[Musique]
est ce que je peux vous confier un
secret
très grande importance
je possède à irkoutsk un perroquet avec
qui je dois en principe célébrer mon
anniversaire
[Musique]
à cette allure il faut pas résister très
longtemps alors 2 heures nous serons
arrivés au prochain relais
[Musique]
marine nous ne pourrons pas aller plus
loin pourquoi il n'y a plus qu'un seul
cheval frais vous n'avez pas de chance
nous en avions encore une paire cela
fait deux minutes mais un cavalier a
pris l'un des deux a regardé loi exige
bien il était sur son char qui gardait
affligé observer son silence autour de
lui rangé salut confrères c'est le ciel
qui vous envoie que comptez-vous faire
de ce cheval probablement du steak haché
car au train où je vais mais rennes ne
porteront pas le voyage une proposition
à vous faire vous avez le cheval qui me
manque
moi un siège qui est pas mieux à votre
examen d'autres camarades
[Musique]
bonjour
voilà j'ai besoin de deux chevaux et
vivement
je veux passer le col avant la nuit
alors donnez moi baril ne l'avons plus
de chevaux viennent donner ma dernière
faire un client ça fait une semaine que
c'est comme ça en tout cas les faire
boire et leur donner de la voix bien sûr
barine vous feriez mieux les ménages et
ils auront beaucoup de mal à franchir le
col qui voudraient perds ton temps là
les marchands de genlis et taurou si
vous êtes pressés d'aller en enfer ça
vous regarde
[Musique]
ça va à nadia
je
l'orage exactement ce dont j'avais peur
[Musique]
à
alors
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
passez moi mon bonnet
merci
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous avez déjà vu un orage en montagne
non
[Applaudissements]
allons-y effet pas la paix
c'est pas la peine de rester là à
neurones et
mais
entre est appliquée boudon
e
mieux
et
ouais
et mes bijoux
et
[Musique]
sauter sauter vie
je n'aimais
les empêcher de reculer
[Musique]
et
venez
koné
i
et
[Musique]
non
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]